歡迎收看趙花
我是趙花
我是凱倫
今天台股終於有一個
比較像樣的跌點
我以為你要說下影線
是跌點
要先有這樣的跌點
我們才會有這樣的下影線
有道理
我們盤中跌停我有在算
一度接近80家
80家跌停
不是下跌喔
是跌停喔
哈哈
但是今天的感受很微妙喔
因為我跟艾倫討論
如果今天只有你的
持股跌停
感覺很奇怪嘛對不對
別人都好好的
可是今天有80家一起跌停的時候
反而今天的感受還好
就會覺得啊
反正全市場就這樣了嘛
這已經不是選不選股的問題了
這是你隨便選
每一個就是往跌停去靠近
哈哈哈哈
而且會讓大家覺得說
如果有那麼多家跌停
拉了一个这么长的下影线
会不会这段时间
你天天在那边提心吊胆
震荡然后都点你自己的股票
反而出现了一个比较好的契机
我觉得就是磨到大家没信心的时候
或许就是迎来反弹的时候
好 没信心或者是觉得这两个月
怎么做都是做白宫
甚至有人还跟我说
本来是红的账面
甚至翻成黑的这么严重
这时候反而要定下心来
可能就是反转的契机要到了
这边的话呢
刚好上礼拜我们也特别提到
资金有在做避险
对不对
到了今天才来学避险来得及吗
你看今天拉下引线
其实我们台湾股市是很抗跌的
我觉得是真的就是洗盘
所以大家有信心
好 这一次的重灾区
其实你说是新闻也不是新闻
一个就是美一还在打
但是因为这一次
油价有一点微微的往上跑
我觉得市场就稍微开始有点紧张了
没有错
其实这一次从上个礼拜
就已经有点这种迹象出来了
就是他们一下这个
伊朗去设那个船嘛
对
那没有人伤亡
可是美军就报复
那一报复就报复了
来回就这样两三次
那到了昨天
我觉得是川普讲了一句话
才让整个的石油价格爆喷
它就是封锁荷姆之海峡
因为上礼拜他没有封锁嘛
上礼拜他就只有说什么MOU结束了嘛
是
那你末月結束對股價有影響
但是今天這一次是石油價格
做了一個蠻明確的暴漲
對那暴漲過程中
大家又開始要往一件事情去做靠攏了
就是到底會不會通膨
那到底要不要升息
又來了
所以又來了晚一次
那再來是今天晚上要公布CPI
其實CPI這次公布的其實是
那個6月的
所以7月公布6月的
所以今天石油價格漲是漲什麼時候
漲7月的
也就是說要8月去反映新的CPI
才會是反映到
這幾天上漲的石油價格
那這一次的CPI已經降到3.8
原本5月是4.2
所以它連預期值就已經下降了
那只要這個3.8低於3.8
平於3.8
其實我覺得對股市上短線來講
應該會是利多
所以這個是我們接下來要持續關注的
那再來另外一個就是大概三週了
三到四週的時間
就是韓國股市已經漲這樣子了
他們呢
要有一個央行利率決策
他們預期
其實我覺得這對他們來講也是短線的利空
他们可能会实施货币紧缩
跟三年来首度升息
其实我觉得对于热钱效应来讲
都会有一些些不太好的迹象
但我觉得OK啦
因为他们也确实嘛
你看人家之前是这样子
这样一倍就上来
短短的时间
全世界上最多的
是的
那当然就是因为有隔壁这个嘛
海力士跟三星的影响
我们看到韩国股市
我们的韩国股市呢
其实已经回到了五月的起涨点
是跌破的
但我们台湾股市
连4万5都破不了
4万4 4万5左右
所以台湾股市真的抗跌
等于反过来说对不对
如果今天联准会看到
本周的CPI并没有失控
以及韩国的政府已经出手要干预
希望能止跌的话
那就是一个从底部
可能要反转的讯号啊
对 那这个时候该怎么办
我觉得现在台湾股市操作难度是偏高的
那在这个整体的状态之中呢
我们还是要注意一下
第一道防线呢
就是要拉高现金水位
没有把握的话就换一点钱回来
沒有錯 或者是你就APP刪掉
就是換錢回來之後APP刪掉
因為你手會癢嘛
對
然後呢 那怎麼了
沒有 我想說APP刪掉
是不是有階段反應
哈哈哈
手就開始
對
怎麼辦
但是這時候沒辦法
所以要提高一些現金水位
然後要降低持股的比例
那當然持股比例
我覺得依照個人的風險程度
偏好去做調整
有的人是七成以下
我就輕鬆自在
可是有的人要降到三成以下
那才會輕鬆自在
那這個大家要自己問問自己
那再來就是剛好趁著這個機會
去泰國留強
本益比的高融資使用率的
或者籌碼比較鬆動的
那就建議呢
可以把資金先首度收回來
然後轉向一些防禦型的
或者是說直接轉現金
去等待下一次機會
那再來第二個呢就是
我這個真的資金太多了
那我現在手上還有錢
但是我怕買了之後
後面我不敢買回來
那怎麼辦
那就是只能用多餘的錢
來做一些避險工具
包含了目前呢
可能就是台子旗
然后跟选择权
还有就是反向的ETF
对那其实台湾的这个工具呢
我觉得算联动性很扎实了啦
对那可是有可能一个状况
你买到中小型个股
但是你去避险的是期货
那期货其实跌幅并没有这么大
因为有台积电
没错 撑腰
对但我觉得都OK啦
就是主要重点是
你有这个东西就不要害怕亏钱
你反而要去期待的就是你的避险工具
可能是亏钱的
因为就代表现货已经赚钱嘛
我们等一下的大来宾
会教大家用个股期避险
是的
就可以比较针对性
对我们就简单讲一下
现在光是以指数期货
就大概分三种
大台小台跟围台
对那大家依照保证金
跟自己的资金需求去算一下
你的比例可能要抓到多少
那当然嘛
优点就是杠杆高嘛
避险效率是最好的
因为它的交易的容量也很大
所以不会有太明确的
可能成交量不公的状态
当然缺点呢
就是当行情一个转折的时候
你的避险部位也会去放大亏损
所以要抓好
因为你要去抓一下
背数大概多少
就是你的现货多少
多少的放空部位是合理的
对
除非你就是
我就是喜欢放空
那这也当然OK
那是另外一种
那是用的操作
那另外就是买POOT
POOT的优势就是损失有限
因为你如果越跌越重
那它这个价格会翻倍去成长
但相对的如果是反方向大涨呢
大涨你最多就是歸零
對 隨歸零糕
沒錯 那當然缺點還有一個
不漲跟不跌呢
那你也會歸零
它會消磨
沒錯 所以它有時間價值的虧損
那再來就反向ETF
就是非常的清晰
指數漲它就是跌
然後呢就是同比例的漲跌
對 所以這個也是一個方式
而且比較輕鬆一點點
因為它比較像是偏現貨的感覺
沒有到那麼大的槓桿
那再來第三個呢就是
好 我現在呢
現金比較多
然后呢可是我又想买东西
就是想要做一点
有点利息也好
是 没错
可是不要再跌了
对的 好
但近期呢
其实还有其他像美金啊
但美债啊
其实我觉得最近都有一点
跟股市同向
那我觉得比较明确的
可能会是美元啦
应该目前的避险的
整个的效应应该是最明显的
日元美元跟瑞朗
那目前就以美元为主
所以美元指数最近拉很凶嘛
对 所以这个大家可以去注意
但我觉得这个可能
大家比較不是這麼常態性
那最簡單的應該是前面那兩個
跟股市比較有關的
好 再來講完之後呢
我們就來看貼盤看一下現在的狀態
我們的大盤呢
今天盤中是跌破了這個前低
然後呢一度接近了月季線的位置
那時候我覺得就怎麼這樣
因為這裡就沒收好了
但是收盤的時候呢
其實有稍微站回來一點點
那今天是留了大概千點左右的下影線
這不是你最喜歡的嗎
脖子以下都是腿啊
对啊
没有这个大概是胸口以下都是腿
还没有到脖子以下
好严格喔
这边我帮他发一条线
这是一个上升趋势轨道
跟下降趋势轨道
三角缩链
但其实今天是空方获胜了
对所以我觉得可以再观察一下
哦 跌破了三角缩链
所以即使留了下一线
你个人还是比较谨慎
所以前面才会准备一些
还是希望大家要有避线意识
是的
我觉得我还是必须讲
你看我们看韩国股市和那个废半
其实台湾股市真的抗跌
因为连季线才在缩链乖离而已
可是呢会不会真的韩国就持续起不来
然后带动我们台湾股市跟着去回落
当然我觉得不是不可能啦
对只是呢我们很明确的嘛
你下去有人接
那我们刚刚提到三角缩链
目前空方式获胜
但空方式呢
其实我们还有几个重点可以去观察
包含呢就是这个季线的位置
跟这个前面低点的位置
我觉得这边都必须要守好了
对所以我觉得这非常重要
那我们刚刚有提到嘛
你事件性如果能够CPI是OK的
然后韩国股市去杠杠
也降了很多融资下来嘛
如果降到一定合理的范围
然后也消耗完卖压
然后台积电来个利多
那我们就直接站回来
全部均线之上
其实也是一个好的现象啦
对对对对
所以我其实
以技术面上来讲
我觉得比较岌岌可危
但以事件性来讲的话
其实我觉得大家关注的重点
就是这礼拜四跟礼拜五
因为台积电下午
礼拜四公布法说嘛
所以法说要反映的是
明天的行情
所以我觉得周五
如果有个好的机会
能够这样子一口气站回来
全部均线之上
那我觉得大家就
会比较稳定一点了
那当然要转强要更多讯号
要过高嘛要过高
这个是后续要观察的
那再贵买就更辛苦一点点
因为加权它有大型股
其实大型股这波还好
中小型刚刚你讲到
打到半年线年线
我后来发现还真的
尤其是千金股
对啊 打到年线
没错
那贵买呢
今天盘中一度跌到7%
接近7%
对 这个是很罕见的
只有跌3%
跌到7%代表
很多股票跌停
都是贵买的股票
对啊 很多高价股
都一堆什么
尤其探针系列的
很多都是重点全值
那我们看到贵买呢
今天收盘价跌破了季线
这是比较糟糕的状况
但是贵买呢
还有前面的支撑区
所以呢
接下来上市跟上跪
你可以再整理
你可以继续跌
但一个重点
你就是今天的低点
不能再破了
破了就基本上就破了
对
但愿意拉脚嘛
表示有人去做承接嘛
那承接就看一下
承接的力道
后面几天能不能延续去向上
来化解目前比较尴尬的状况
因为这里如果跌破
这个就是一个大头部
这里有一个支撑区嘛
一只脚两只脚
这是第三只嘛
你第三只脚破
这边就很明确
就下来就要消化掉
到时候的卖牙会更辛苦
所以我们希望能够撑好
对 撑下去
加油 好不好
那贵买其实有一个
细晶圆双雄
环球金跟中美金都在贵买
今天相对很强
是啊
那它在这种逆势的墙
你觉得是要把资金
挪到这种逆势墙的吗
我觉得以形态来讲
其实他们今天是整理
那整理后面有拉起来
所以可能单日整理
就有点结束的讯号
我觉得趋势是强势的
那目前共识比较高可能比那些
好少喔
很少啊
那再来看到这个全资股
台积联电来举例
是的
台积电目前其实呢
守住2400
那2500没过
所以呢就是2400到2500的
区间震荡
对啊今天还可以小说红
你看我们基线在这里
那是距离
这个大盘破这个低点嘛
那台积电是连碰都没碰到所以台积电是抗跌的那抗跌过程中就看一下在法说前抗跌因为利空嘛就应该是比较偏空的环境那如果能够法说来个激情那我觉得唐股市就会有激情
对那再来是联电
联电呢近期的走路
今天都在处置中
礼拜四出关
所以也是7月16
那7月16就看这个
我们的这一个金元代工双雄
有没有机会在周四或周五的时候
有一个起表现的状态
联电呢近期呢
有一个发债的状态
然后又处置中
所以目前价格
目前的走勢比较尴尬
那其实连电来讲也相对抗跌了
所以今天又拉了一个这个
这个才是脖子以下都是脚
对
哦哦哦哦哦
他的头好扁哦
对
所以我觉得他今天这根是一个
不错的讯号
那就是等一个处置嘛
然后占回全部均线
其实我觉得就可以稍微期待一下
连电的未来基本面
应该还是蛮值得期待的
好这个是帮大家讲的全资股的部分
好那当然下段
我们再来讲到个股的部分
刚刚有特别提到
现在盘面上我们受到影响的美意战争
韩国股市的去杠杆
但是这两件事情反而现在看起来都有转机
我们不妨来观察一下
只是之前如果没有学会避行或避风的朋友
下一段要仔细听起来了
为什么最近塑化在涨
其实现在塑化不是纯塑化
他们是有避风加AI的功能
好 來吧
我們呢 在上禮拜的時候
也有來講過塑膠塑膠
傳產啦
我們上禮拜有來講傳產
上個禮拜就有講到避風了
所以如果上禮拜就有先避風的朋友
也許今天的感受會比較好一點
尤其如果有買到軍工的
可能也不會覺得大盤多嚴重
對 然後買到塑膠應該也還OK
對 其實也蠻強勢的
那最近台素质寶呢
表現都非常強勁
那當然裡面其中一個最強勁的
領頭羊就是我們的南亞
南亞
前面還創高
前面還漲5%呢
很厲害的
太扯了
是的 那目前來說
整個台素智寶
第二季獲利有好的狀態
那法人認為
目前的評價是比較低估的
有相關的
中東石化產能戰士的受損
以及俄羅斯煉油廠
有導致產能的下滑
那塑化的供需結構
正在做改善
那以及就是產品的利差
因為它煉化成整個的
可以可用的這個染料
它是有一个立查在的空间
好那另外一个就是石油价格上涨
所以他们是受贿的
好那受贿的过程中呢
当然今天
原本像南亚
像台化他们讲的是
南亚是做CCL嘛
那台化它是有切入AI相关的材料厂
对所以受贿
前面这两个股价原本比较强势
但今天台数跟台数化一起来
主要就是因为今天石油价格
油价
也是做了一个很明确的上涨
所以呢在整个行情
比较不确定的时候
反而有一些资金啊
刚刚有提到避险的概念
也可以拨一小部分
来到传产相关的个股
因为位阶也偏低
尤其其实他们也跟AI有切到边
又有价格的 油价的影响
所以今天的表现
我们来看一下里面几位
首先这个虽然不是树化股
但是是台树集团的个股
或者说南亚集团里面的双雄
南亚科 南电
南电也很猛
这个更夸张了
它没有头
他就直接下影线
他只长了脚
就看到一双脚在跑而已
就这样子
你看而且不只他
景硕也长这样子
景硕是跌停锁了整个上半场
然后大概12点多的时候
他那个就急拉上去
所以你看我们资金很明确的
有几个族群
其实除了直接传产
大家可以注意
像是ABF宅伴
景硕 金星 南电
真顶可以歪
今天普遍拉下影线
另外一个是细金人族群
像是中美金 环球金
还有是那个谁
合金
还有台胜科
对台胜科今天
涨停啊
一盘中V的时候
他就直接拉涨停
没错
所以其实你可以注意到
以电子相关
其实还是有族群
是有人有共识高的
那现在共识最低的就是
被动元件嘛
被动元件好惨
对
被动实营元件
主动元件
原本都是
大家赚钱元件
涨价三兄弟
现在都是
整理的
比较大的状态
对
所以資金共識比較少
那就會比較難操作
不過南亞科蠻猛的
他禮拜五對不對
颱風價還來開法說
是有得到回報的
對喔 很多
他就撐住了啊
不然你看三線還是那個樣子
真的
而且南亞科目標價最近都被調升
調高喔
有再拉一波上來
那你看到我們今天南亞科
昨天開高走低
今天開低走高
還是在全部均線之上
其實很強啊
比華華麵跟那個誰
那個萬宏都還來得厲害一點
那南天就不用說了嘛
就是回車完工方缺口
碰五日均就拉長下引線
所以目前的形態上
這個都是少數偏強
尤其南電又更強一點
因為它是創新高
那奈亞科至少在全部均線之上
也相對強勁
所以整個的奈亞集團
都還是有一個集團性表現
買到奈亞集團就這一波贏家
沒錯
所以我們就先來看一下這個本人
母公司 蔡素
蔡素集團本人
他就是一個
橫跨了原料 塑料 特化
跟高階纖維的化石龍頭
那其实方开长线的走势来讲
这里绝对是低点
因为我们拉比较近一点
但是短线呢
确实也是一个
蛮明确的一个多方形态
那今天呢能够开低
应该说它是开高
然后盘中有走低
然后尾盘再拉高
那拉高过程中呢
全部均线之上
前高又在这附近
其实很容易就继续做一个向上延伸
那这个呢就是
第一个人以位结构低
那第二个它跟电子
是比较没有联动性相关的
那目前来说资金比较不确定
确实是有往台数去做靠拢的
但是这边也要提醒大家
如果我们就像我们刚刚上面所说的
礼拜四礼拜五
如果能够有一些激励的行情
电子去做反弹
那记得哦
这个可能也会是一个
被卖出的主要主纪
就是钱可能会跑掉
会从这边再回电子去
没错
所以我才会说
你可以拨一些资金进来
但就不是主轴
我觉得主轴还是会摆在AI身上
那这里
譬如说你可能手上摆个两成的资金
跑到这个传产的部分
我觉得可以做一个避险的状态
那也可以享受短线的一个动能的效益
这是台数
台数目前的形态非常不错
那再来另外一个呢
当然就还是要看一下我们的南亚
这真的是厉害啊
没错
南亚我们之前就跟大家说
它就是这个从
它可以一条龙自己去生产相关CCL的东西
那波纤纱 波纤布CCL它都可以去做
那市场已经定位成这个高阶的电子级的材料
这一个状态
那跟日中坊是有合作的
然后呢
M8 M9呢近期有去讲
已经认证通过了
所以今天的
昨天就直接先涨停板嘛
今天开D马上就有人
去推到一个相关的高点
相对的高点
而且是创下新高的
我觉得它好难喔
其实谁没买过南亚呢
在PCB好的时候
大家其实都有投资过南亚
你看前面涨过了
然后节目
我想大部分人
应该前面都被洗光光了
我也是
那后面怎么办呢
对不对
100块以下被洗掉
现在200块
是的
南亚呢
这个据传有被调升目标价
有啊 大摩那时候调到200
已经最近说到了三开头
但这个就大家听听
这我不晓得
对 只是有
市场有这样的传闻
但我觉得就是回归到一个重点
旧线论线
它就是一个强势的
沿着MH去垫高的结构
那只要MH没跌破
这个多方趋势
应该就是维持上升的结构
短线的动能是非常明确的
那目标价大家就不用管它
因为目标价这个谁都可以说嘛
那只不过确实市场对于南亚的共识
近期应该是持续偏高
不只是这边高
这边也高
而且在新的状态之下
都持续的有去更高的期待在它身上
那尤其是行情这么烂
你看人家还可以创新高
以动能来讲
筹码来讲已经就是强势了
所以这边也可以持续关注一下
那再来另外一个呢就是台速化
相对电子比重低
它就比较弱势些
真的弱势蛮多的
但也相对的
它的涨跌就会稍微比较小一点点
比较温和
对 你看在前面这几天
前两天有一个开低
然后拉高的下影线
那在昨天创了一个反弹高
在今天续创反弹高
而且成交量是持续的去放大的
那我觉得这个位阶都很低
所以目前来说有动能
位阶够低
我觉得都可以去注意一下
能不能有跟着去补涨的机会
但它跟油价的联动可能会比较高
所以大家要留意油价
沒錯 所以台塑化也為什麼這一波
前面的動靜都比較小
因為確實嘛 南亞跟台化
它長的題材不是只有油價而已
對 它們是電子相關的材料去做反應的
最後一個就是台化
台化也是我覺得可以好好關注的一檔
它的線為什麼長得跟人家好像有點不一樣
怎麼會有那個大黑K啊
確實啊 這邊是盤整嘛
對啊 人家都好端端的
南亞這邊也
這邊也會喔
一點點像 一點點像
好好好
跟奶昭創高的它没有啊
对
所以我觉得台化也是可以去关注一下
台化在之前就
目前应该是这样讲
就是有切入相关的散热跟碳化系半导体
还有离电池的材料新兴领域
所以在前一阵子
它为什么能够拉这两根
就是永远有新闻出来说
它是AI台化
对有积极切入相关的材料厂
那目前来说呢
这个上升趋势都非常明确
那当然这边整理比较大幅度的一点
比較大幅一點的整理
然後回測下來之後呢
昨天紅吃黑
今天站回全部均線
而且這兩天成交量有持續的放大
我會覺得這個結構
應該還滿明確的可以持續去墊高
那也就是說呢
以台塑世保來講
有傳產的避險功能
那有一些各自的AI題材
那有一些相關跟油價
剛好油價在上漲
又去跟到節奏的
我覺得都可以稍微關注一下
當然同理
我覺得除了南亞跟台化之外
如果油價開始跌
那如果电子明确的回到了
资金回到电子身上
那记得可能就会遇到了一个
短线修正的状态
所以他们是比较反向的族群
大家要自己再稍微注意一下
那当然现在就电子不太好
所以短线就持续看能不能
向上的去做反应
好 等于上礼拜有讲
像这个是N字形走势
回落的时候可以注意找买点
希望大家可以多了解一下
这类型的族群
没错
那为什么不讲军工呢
军工也是避险的
军工礼拜四就要过法案了
我觉得法案过完会不会
短线有一些利多出境
那当然我觉得过法案就代表
未来一定会有营收
所以利多出境完
短线修正到相对低
我觉得也可以看啦
因为之前它都起不来
就是因为法案过不去嘛
所以市场对他们就
没有讨论度了
那现在有讨论度了
那第一段已经上去了
我觉得就可以先等看看
好 像今天
虽然我们盘中有个V转
不过我觉得也是要提醒大家
韩国在一个去杠杆的过程
台湾也许杠杆没有开得这么高
可是我们之前这个央行总裁
杨金融也有提到
AI的发展不是大问题
但是杠杆开太满是一个问题
所以我们还是要把避险的方式
资金的流向
我们希望在这一集交给大家
那等一下我们还有大来宾
会更仔细的去说
如果您是用个股期
或是选择权该怎么做
以及有没有什么东西跌下来之后
他觉得反而是所谓的买点浮现
那需要今天节目所有的图卡资料
记得来一下我们赵华艾伦说的
YouTube频道
我们都会免费放在首页的提文栏里面给大家
那等一下就期待大来宾吧
欢迎回来赵华
今天呢我们的大来宾很特别
我们都听过老师嘛
我们都听过学生嘛
那老师的老师叫什么
就是老老师
所以今天来的是老老师吗
老师的老师
辈分很高辈分很高没错但是他身高很高是真的这个是真的其实我们之前有排名过就是我们认识的人里面他其实是第二高的来宾
所以后来我们就决定叫第一高的来宾都不要来了
哎呦 讲出来谁
那他现在来到
非常多人都很喜欢听他的讲解
因为他讲话中带有一种安定人心的力量
然后又有一种黑色幽默
我們先來歡迎他
因為他是少數腳可以直接放在地上
輕輕鬆鬆的樣子
就是齊全王子張林忠 忠哥
主持人好 大家好
忠哥很溫文如雅
然後身高又很高
忠哥幾公分
186 對
所以被問爛的問題就是
那為什麼不去打籃球對不對
186其實在台灣也不太算高
但在金融業應該算是高了
對 不過我跟今年NBA總冠軍
那個尼克隊的Bronson一樣高
是
對對對 所以應該也不算矮啦
但因為我現在年紀漸長
也50多歲了
身高太高其實也沒什麼用
只是覺得有點佔位子而已
對對對
上面的空氣不是比較好嗎
空氣是差不多的
沒有什麼差別
對對對
好 不過這樣鐘哥在我們金融界
可以是金融界的MVP啊
好 因為之前的話
宗哥本來是在家自營了一段時間
而且從事的是量化交易
那現在跑到富邦期貨當副總經理
其實進入到體制的時候
你有段時間
可能是覺得比較有壓力的
對 因為之前其實我在
其實台灣前三大券商
我待過兩家
就是像元大跟群應
其實我都待過
那後來就是我自己在外面
有去傳授
不是 講傳授有一點奇怪
就是教大家怎麼去寫程式
做量化交易
是
因為其實這個節目
我都會看
那我之前看那個婉婷
她的座右銘是
她不是很聰明
但是她很勤勞
對 很努力
那我覺得我跟她相反
怎麼說
我不是很勤勞
但是我很聰明
我就想到說
因為我們要交易對不對
我根本不可能用手跟眼睛盯盤
是
對 我一定要用電腦幫忙我
所以我從大概20年前
我就發現這件事情
是
對 那時候其實還沒有夜盤
但你看其實現在夜盤
下午3點開對不對
那什麼時候時候
明天早上五点钟
那正常人有办法去跟嘛
用眼睛跟手下单
比较不可能
万一要睡觉啊
对啊
那我在奇货公司
大概一二十年
遇过一个人他可以
那为什么他可以
因为他失眠
他晚上不用睡觉
所以他可以
那正常人做不到
那你就只能靠电脑帮忙
对所以我一直在朝向这方面
来做研究跟教育
你看老师
老师真的很不一样
大部分人都会说
我的天资还好
可是我很努力
他说我是很聪明
果然是老师
所以他的座右铭也特别不一样
他座右铭叫做海水退潮了
你就知道谁没有穿裤子
对啊
因为其实金融市场是这样
这两年也是大多头
那我们等于是
我们随便设一档飞标
都会中
所以你买什么股票
好像都会涨
你不要买到传产就好了
可能你聪明啦
对
然后就是我觉得
有些人用的交易方式
其实因为我交易的每一笔
我都要去回測過
假設我覺得
這個KD站在這邊黃金交叉
我覺得可以買
那為什麼買
那其實KD是不好用的
你可能要加其他條件
所以我會加上其他的去量化回測
那測完之後
我才有信心去進場做交易
那我覺得
例如說現在行情比較震盪
可能以前的方式
未必就會賺到錢
所以當然海水退潮
你有穿褲子的人
你就會看到有穿
那你沒穿
可能就會被市場上面淘汰
所以現在到今年的這個H2
就是下半年
我覺得會比較稍微
交易難度提高之後
我覺得這個地方
會看出誰真的會比較OK一點
好 多頭市場的時候
可能大家怎麼樣交易都會贏
所以鍾哥要提出的一個提醒
是下半年如果震盪加劇
難度加高的時候
那就要有本事的人
才能坐在這裡了
不過我們先來看一下
進入到鍾哥的教學之前
我們先來看一下
今天的齊全抽馬
因為剛好今天鐘哥來的時機點很巧
盤中下殺1700點
而且明天是台紙期結算
今天外資還在加空間
2000多口
以齊全王子來看
到底發生什麼事
對 其實因為我
我覺得在市場上面
在講期貨跟選擇的比較少
真的是相對少
所以一開始我們說
為什麼叫我老師的老師
因為以前我要在期貨公會
當他們來授載職訊的時候
我要去負責授課
所以很多人會看到我
大概就是
因為我在幫他們開課這樣子
那當然你只要在看齊全的話
你就會發現
它不是永遠都是偏向多方的
它就會有一些空方訊號出來
例如說我們看最近7月份的盤
感覺就比之前不太一樣
4月5月真的是什麼都亂找
我們看到很多年輕人
一樣開槓桿
那其實韓國人也是
韓國人是不管在什麼領域
他都做到很大
他們就是很剛烈
民族性就是這樣
所以他現在就是壓最大
可能稍微不好
他就反正就停損
要不然我乾脆就了斷
但這是很不是
不是鼓勵這種行為
好 那我們來看一下最近的盤勢
那最左邊是外資
外資的多單一直都很多
我們看這個黑色的線就是大盤
大盤上工資
其實外資的空單一直都相當的多
累積到8萬口以上
那其實外資這個8萬口
可以規避掉多少現貨的風險
其實很多人並不知道
你可以算一下
假設你用4萬5千點
大盤的指數
那1點是200
然後再存上這個契約規格
那其實大概是7500億
就是外資在規避
7500億現貨的風險
但它不是真的拿這麼多錢出來
因為期貨是保證金交易
所以大概是5600億
它就可以規避這個風險
那你看
因為現在價差有時候很大
那外資還會套利
所以這部分的單子
它含有的是
避險單跟套利單都有
那很難去明確的確界定出來
那因為明天是結算
所以可以觀察一下結算之後
如果還是維持在8萬口
我覺得是中性
如果到9萬 10萬以上
可能要特別的小心
因為明天禮拜四
下午2點有一個台經營的法說
後天
對 禮拜四 對
法說會之前
大家常常說是會上漲
法說會下跌
那是這兩年的慣性
但是今年沒有
因為法說會前沒有漲
所以你說法說會後
應該照理說也不會跌
可能是要反方向
應該是要
我覺得有機會能夠蓄積
蓄積的能量能夠做反彈
所以外資空單低格不能太多
再來我們看到自營商很特別
自營商最近的選擇權
它是偏向多方的
它的買權賣權都是做買進
那買權買比較多了
買了一萬兩千口
賣權買七千
這個很明顯大概差了五千口左右
自營商因為它的操作壓力是很大的
我們看很多的騎貨商自營的部位
他們其實拓利都還不錯
因為今年畢竟是多頭
他們這邊其實是偏向多方的
所以我們說
從碼面外資這個是一換
那這個是一號
再來我們看四個指標
一個是小台
一個是微台
那小台跟微台
以誰為準呢
以微台為準
因為小台就是以前的大台
現在大台一口保證金
大概是63到67萬左右
如果你是網路開期貨戶的話
你連一口大台你都下不進去
好像有限50萬對不對
限50萬
對 所以根本散戶沒辦法做大台
那小台就是以前的這個中石戶
那很多量化交易的都在做小台
所以你會看到
這個大盤上漲的時候
那小台在做多
大盤在下跌
其實它的小台它是會降的
就是跟盤它是比較貼
那比較不貼就是這個圍台
圍台比較像是散戶
那我們看其實在今天
大盤不是下跌最多到1700嘛
雖然最後是V轉
但是它的這個多單今天還增加
什麼意思呢
就是反正今年1月到
我只要看到大盤往下走
我去買進就對了
過幾天可能都會上漲
當然我們也有統計過了
例如說你看單日如果跌3%以上
你在下一個假日的收盤去買
你大概過3天5天之後
其實它都會回到原本的起跌點
這是真的喔
所以大家都會覺得
好像這樣是對的
凹單會贏
當然因為覺得AI趨勢
今年會持續沒有太大問題
所以覺得你這樣做可能可以
所以我們從場面看起來
現在就是三壞一壞
三萬一好
對三萬一好
其實
那不太好啊
對 結算前看起來是沒有太好
尤其是今天大盤跌了之後
他們還增加
我原本是期待說
如果今天下跌
這個地方有稍微降一下的話
結算可能有機會
能夠稍微小談一下
但是從雙場面看起來
真的不是太漂亮
因為可能還要看一下
我們節目播出的時候
應該融資餘額也出來了
看一下有沒有殺一些融資
但是我也問過鐘哥一個問題
他為的很犀利
我說我可能變聰明圍台
凹單會贏啊
做多必勝啊
我覺得不會
但莊哥很堅持他說不會
對 因為我待過很多期貨商
其實我們可以去算一下
客戶的損益
那長期大概還是比較不太理想
是 對
好 所以這個指標圍台做多
還是要留意
是 好 那當然我們這次的話
槓桿 因為期貨就是槓桿
選擇權就是槓桿
這次的槓桿是從韓國引爆的
引爆還不只亞洲股災
其實美國的科技股也跌很深
那這一波的這樣的韓國槓桿
去槓桿
你覺得是不是已經算告一段落
其實最近已經殺得相當多了
其實韓國誰在用槓桿
都是30歲以下的人
就是20歲到30歲
這個比例其實相當高
那他們在這個從上
應該最近一週嘛
大概已經去掉了
大概600億的槓桿
那什麼叫槓桿呢
就是它的完全被
整個倉位是歸零
就是完全都不见
他们的这个交易制度跟台湾
反而是更不太一样
那台湾其实也有在开杠杆
那谁呢像这个正二
有一批正二组
就是目前累积到2000亿以上
那很多人会说
我做正二根本就不是在开杠杆
我是买ETF
其他人根本搞不清楚
你买正二投信就是帮你买期货
买这个台积电的期货
或是台子期的期货
所以其实你就是在开杠杆
那我们来看这个韩股
这是我们把过去一个礼拜
它的市值的排行
那格子越大就是市值越大
那你看三星電子跟海力士
这两档的比重加起来是65%
那这个台湾的台积电是40%
所以你说载机指数
其实韩国更严重
目前已经变成这样的状况
所以你只要看到盘中
它一有风吹草动
大盘其实就下去
当然它今天也拉很快
它今天这个V转的速度
其实相当的快
那我们从这个资金面看起来
大概钱都跑到
其实只有一家
像KB金融集團
綠色是上漲的
上漲大概就是小小的一塊一塊
但是主要的增結
都是在這些下跌的太多
紅色是下跌
這邊跌兩成 跌24% 對不對
那我們可以看
從這張我們可以衍生到三個
我覺得你可能要特別留意
像我覺得最重要是第二個
就是韓國如果繼續這樣跌的話
因為我們知道今年上漲的股市
其實沒有很多
你看歐股 陸股跟香港股票
其實都是往下走的
那你跟AI有扯上邊其實才會漲
所以台灣跟韓國也是首當其衷
還有日本
那如果韓國繼續修正的話
其實台股的相關供應鏈
可能就會有個連動的外衣效應
所以你會看
這幾個禮拜其實都是
我們知道韓國歷史上有熔斷13次
那最近一個月好像熔斷了7次
對
那以前巴菲特說
他一輩子沒有看過熔斷幾次
對 那其實
就是我覺得現在的市場
跟以前完全不一樣
因為資金的這個結構已經不同了
所以這要留意一下那當然記憶體的話如果韓國繼續跌他們像南亞科華房店可能就要要特別留意一下不過我們可以看到幾個南亞科我覺得他有點在止跌
像昨天
昨天已經要大盤不太好
但南亞科我覺得他跌得很少
那今天也是
今天他甚至是翻紅5%以上
那為什麼呢
待會我們會跟大家說一下
我們怎麼樣去選擇這樣的方式
所以從韓國看台灣
我覺得最重要的重點
大概就是他不能再繼續跌
他可能要有這個震盪打底的味道
我覺得對AI對記憶體
其實都是好的事
其實台股的槓桿型商品
沒有那麼多
德頓宇在台灣做槓桿型商品
所以反而這一波我們的修正
沒有那麼的激烈
也不知道是好是壞
可是大家的體感
說實話最近不是太好
都講說兩個月的獲利全部都回吐了
沒錯
全部都回吐了
甚至如果追高的朋友
可能帳面還紅翻黑的都有
我覺得韓國人
因為他們太聰明了
而且他們的我們剛才說性格剛烈
他賺就要賺很快
就要賺很快 要賺很多
那我們說急救的這個避震包
就是你在地震的時候
要準備一個東西
裡面可能會有水
剛艾倫說他要放電動
我說要放電動 他說要放水
人家誤會他了
我誤會他了
那你要放什麼
其實我們家沒有這個
應該要趕快準備一下
我們家沒有這個 你們都有
我有啊 我家裡有
真的喔
放在哪裡 冰箱旁邊
我都放在一個小角落
我還有那個
它有一個箱子是放急救用品的
我還有放那個
裡面有食物對不對
對
放十年的食物
十年的那種乾糧
我還有入水收集器
十年就是可以放十年的吃的
真的
就是有一些乾糧可以放非常多年的
好
好 那我要準備一下
那我們看
避難包就是大盤震盪的時候
其實有兩個工具
大家可以簡單選一下
一個就是選擇權
一個就是股票起貨
選擇權我想那個趙華常常在說
就是那個雲翔哥買
買POOT就全台股
那最近買POOT
如果他持續有買的話
最近應該還不錯
可是他說最近不好買
他說最近多空都不好買
所以他沒有賺到錢嗎
買POOT應該照理說會賺到一些吧
他說不太好買
我們簡單舉例好了
像這個是今天盤中的
我們選的權叫做T字報價
那左邊是買權
右邊是賣權
那這個是今天盤中
稍微有拉起來的時候
那黃色這個就叫做價品
也就是加權指數現在的位置
那你看
那往右上方就是價外
價外你看就像44250的賣權
它是沒有價值的
因為還沒有跌到那邊
那你看今天現在是223
然後漲了75
代表它昨天是多少
就是223-75
所以它今天已經漲了
這樣算起來
報酬率50%
那我們看一般股票
你不可能漲到50%
但選擇權常常會有這種獲利的機會
所以我們說
如果你比較積極的話
你其實可以買進價外的賣權
那雲翔哥應該就在做這件事情
對 然後他就說
最近不知道為什麼
他的價外賣權都很貴
他常常要下單的時候
會超出他覺得能夠下的價格
我覺得現在因為我覺得
肇事他們好像沒有那麼積極
所以你那個買價賣價
他有點差距
價格比較不漂亮
那你可以這樣去做
然後你就壓
行情異常波動下跌
而且要跌很大
像這個2025年4月份的時候
那川普那次清明節
很多人這個選擇權的Pud
其實都賺我看有1000倍
我們看脆上如果那個是真的
當然現在AI很多了
所以這個是買Pud比較積極的
那如果是比較保守的
你可以做消極避險
你可以去賣出價外的買權
那這個其實巴菲特他們很喜歡做
假設我持有蘋果
例如說這個350塊
我覺得它不可能漲到400
我就去賣出蘋果400塊的扣
那这样讲好像比较复杂
其实就是去收权利金
例如说你看
假设现在盘中是44500
那我觉得因为最近大盘很弱嘛
外资空担也很多
不太可能涨到44750
我就去卖出这个收329
那329的话
大概可以赚15000
16000左右的权利金
这是消极型的避险
所以这种是选择权的方式
那这个我有个问题想问一下
因为那个选择权这一块
它其实因为现在台股波动很大嘛
你可能一分钟就四五百点去了
那如果我要做避險
很容易就直接架外轉架內
那那過程中
它的成交量才會放大
或者是怎麼樣
可是現在就是整個的
範圍它其實有點窄
那如果遇到急漲急跌
我是不是也其實相對很難
去跟同方向的進場
它如果急漲的話
其實它這一整串成交量大
它會跟著往下跑
它就是會隨時都會移動的
所以目前如果你是要在盤中
然後我們就要做靜月
像今天是禮拜二嘛
你就要交易禮拜三結算的選擇權
如果禮拜四呢
你要交易禮拜五結算
你不能再往外
再往外其實就沒有量了
對 你只能找
禁月結算的 禁週的
最近結算的期月
這是比較安全 對
了解 對
除了選擇權
我們再講一下股期好了
好 各股期貨
對 那股期貨
大家應該會覺得比較簡單
就有比較熟悉了
現在做各股期
因為期貨商也有講
現在成交量有變大了
對 沒錯
你就是期貨商嗎
對
今年其實選擇選擇量是縮
但是這個
骨骑的量真的是變得很大
很多人現貨做不夠
他就甚至移到骨骑來
或是處置骨太多
就去做骨骑
對 因為其實骨骑也是開槓桿
大概開了7.5倍左右
最後我們今天來講避險
因為是避震包對不對
好 假設這個人拿一個籃球
看起來很像是我
很像是你嗎
但是你的比例
好像比這個修長很多
是 好 假設我有群創好了
那很不巧的話
我也買在這邊相對低對不對
大盤這個群創這邊壓下來的時候
我覺得買進6月12
我買進50.5
我買10張
那我放到現在
我都不想要賣
因為我覺得群創
它可能有這個細光紙相關的一些
剪出型封撞的問題
題材
我覺得它以後可能會上500
對不對
那我就不想賣嘛
那不想賣怎麼辦
因為最近的盤很正
我們就可以去做避險
那第一個是完全避險
10張的這個群創就空無口
這很簡單
就是因為一口是兩張
那什麼時候避險呢
簡單給大家一個概念
你可以拉一條均線
例如說這個MA20
就是這一條
紅色這一條
那看這邊是不是碰到了
所以就可以去空五口
7月13號跌破月線
好那我們看
我們空古期的獲利
完全避險的話
古期這個地方會獲利6.6萬
那如果你做部分避險
你不要全空
你空三口
你會賺3.9萬
現貨都不動
因為現貨的獲利就是
在這個地方6.9萬
所以如果你完全避險的話
你就是現貨加期貨會有13.5
那你完全避險的話
大概會有10.86
那如果你什麼都不做
或是你沒有股票期貨的戶頭的話
你就見股嘛
你就是剩下這邊就是6.9萬
你只有這邊6.9萬
你是不是就跟13.5
還有10.8
其實都有一些差距
那國具
最近跌好慘
對 那國具它就有小型的國具
那很簡單你就把它除以這個
因為大的話是2000股
小的就是100股
所以一樣假設這個阿中
持有國具
我有三張好了
我在這邊買
6月8號我買708買三張
那市值是212萬
那一樣方法也相同
你拉一條這個均線
假設這個紅色這一條是這個月線
是不是在這邊跌破
這個箭頭應該在這裡
這邊跌破
跌破的價位你就去放空
那假設完全避險
因為國具我們說它是100股
所以你要空30口
那這個價格比較高
所以就有差距了
你空股期的這個獲利是66萬
那你現貨呢
現貨賺21萬
現貨還比較少
為什麼
因為你在這邊買
現在跌到這裡
已經快跌回去了
你這樣畫上去
其實當然是平
但你現貨
它還是賺21萬
那股期就差到66萬
也就是
如果你什麼都不管它的話
你的現股
你只有這樣子
可能就吐掉了
對 但你積極的去
面對你的交易
甚至是放空的話
其實你就會發現
這邊你會多66萬出來
所以為什麼我們一直在推廣這種方式
所以盡量用避險的心情先做
先不要用摸頭的方式在想
對啊 因為你持有很多的現貨
就像雲翔哥也是
他可能有幾億嘛
那他可能買幾十萬幾百萬的
賣應該都還好
我們這節目在背後
一直幫人家那個
好 當然我們剛剛講到的是避險
那我們還是希望在下跌的時候
很多人的心態
還是希望自己能撿股票
那買也怕 對不對
賣也怕
但是這邊的話
因為鐘哥跟我們聊過
你其實一趟交易可能做5天而已
所以是一個快攻戰術
我覺得現在不用抱太長了
那我提供給大家一個
簡單的一個方式
我們就找三個這個大因子
第一個就是
我覺得融資要增加
因為最近股票有融資才會漲
反而是要融資增加
對 然後第一個是這個
基金ETF持有50檔以上
這個也很重要
因為有投信在顧
第三個是20日均線上漾
这是斜率只要上升的
我会把它选出来
那再加上我们刚才说的
停损停利跟持有时间
其实我们长期回测
报酬率都还蛮高的
那以现在来说
我们持有的标题大概是这些
那今天符合的
其实有两档
一个是南亚科
那一个是3037的星星
这两档就是你今天开盘
8点它就告诉你可以买
那什么时候买
我们在9点钟买
对那你看南亚科
今天开盘买
到最后它是涨5%
那其实绩效是还不错的
所以我們都回測過
我覺得這樣可行
然後再去找標地之後
我覺得這樣操作起來
我就會比較安心一點
所以都是9點鐘
現貨開盤的時候
期貨我們就會進場
對
不會等一下說
例如說9點半
可能有隔日衝出來
對不對
看一下量真的有沒有放大
這些先不考慮
我們不考慮
我們就是固定在那個時候
然後沒有感情
像機器人一樣的執行
是
那你就寫個程式
叫它執行就好了對不對
對 那其實坊間
有一些軟體
其實券商也有
這個有機會我們再來跟大家介紹
好 這很重要
好 所以選出來的話
這邊一檔一檔標題
幫我們解讀一下
對 那你看像南亞科
我們剛才說第一個月線要上升
所以它還是上升的 對不對
那雖然昨天收黑
但沒關係 因為我撈出來了
所以我今天開盤附近
我可能這邊就買進
那剛好今天B轉
所以拉到一個這個
上升的一個狀態
那往下看融資
最近10天它是增加比較多的
所以才被我們會減出來
這是南亞科
再來我們看到的是新興
新興現在看起來
均線好像有一點下彎
但是在昨天以前
它是上升的
一樣融資增加最近相當多
然後月線正在上升
所以一樣我們把它找出來
因為投信也買了很多
所以我覺得
可能它這邊晃一晃
還是有機會能夠慢慢的上工
那剛才那個是今天符合的
那接下來我們看兩檔是
在前五天內其實它已經買過
像廣達
你看廣達一樣
它在前面的融資
是慢慢的在增加
那月線它其實沒有下降
大概是有點走生
所以一樣我們把它挑出來
這可以留意一下
老AI最近機器相當低
它除了長這一段之外
最近都沒有表現
再來最後一檔是這個封測
封測的龍頭就是它
那我們看融資一樣增加了相當多
這個地方
然後月線上完
雖然昨天黑棒 今天也黑棒
但是一樣我們把它挑出來之後
還是會按照我們的基率來執行
所以這次檔
其實大家都可以去留意看看
其實看起來都是全值比較大的耶
反而最近大型全之谷在抗跌这件事情上
还是表现得比较优异
美国也是啊
美国现在Big7在上一个礼拜的表现都还不错
是
所以买中小型股的朋友
可能刚刚那一套避险策略要学起来
没错
今天很谢谢钟哥来到现场
老师的老师
对我们还在上课
其实大家可以列试一下
因为台湾的杠杆引商品不多啦
就大家除了去做政二
反向来看的话
选择权的避险
个股期的避险其实蛮重要的
沒錯